really great news for johnny depp the
trial
that has dominated the america for the
past few weeks
the defamation case from johnny depp
against his ex-wife amber heard who
accused johnny of beating her
the verdict finally came out yesterday
as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled amber heard i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
in the washington post online edition
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath that has
to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms hurd answer yes
the state question the statement was
about mr depp answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the
defamatory implication
was designed and intended by ms heard
answer
yes question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr depp
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
boom total victory judgment for johnny
depp for 15 million dollars he he
lost on one much lesser charge in the
counter suit from amber heard so i think
he lost on a 2 million dollar judgment
there but he won on the 15 million
dollar judgment so this is just total
vindication for johnny depp why do i
care i don't particularly care about
johnny depp i don't i certainly don't
care about amber heard
it is important though
one i care because our daily wire makeup
artist has been absolutely obsessed with
this case and so i feel like i'm just
very invested in it through osmosis
because in the makeup room i've heard a
lot of this case but two because
this represents the death of the metoo
movement this represents the death of
time's up and believe all women no you
shouldn't believe all women because some
women are liars women just like men can
lie they can say things that aren't true
and in some cases women are stone-cold
sociopaths as it would appear this lady
is here just got caught in egregious
lies caught on tape
admitting to lies and threatening to
destroy this guy's career
so a total vindication for johnny depp
and an end of the metoo movement this
all stemmed from a 2018 op-ed that the
sloppy editors at the washington post
allowed amber heard to run so because of
the extremely low journalistic standards
at the washington post amber heard is
now bankrupt this is the most expensive
op-ed in the history of journalism
and that op-ed was a big part of the me
too movement as it was on the rise
now that's all over amber heard issued a
statement she said the disappointment i
feel today is beyond words i'm
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still was not enough to stand
up to the disportionate power influence
and sway of my ex-husband what are you
talking about lady
all of the influence all of the
political power was on your side we've
just come out of a movement where the
ubiquitous call around the country was
believe all women no matter how flimsy
their claims no matter how little
evidence they had all of the evidence in
this case was on the side of johnny depp
including you in your own words
admitting certain things
your closest confidants contradicting
what you were saying video evidence
contradicting the claims that you were
making
and even then the the only reason that
johnny depp won this cases is because we
had that video is because we had that
audio still there was so much power and
influence on your side
so she says this is a step back for
women this is so terrible and then she
says i believe johnny's attorneys
succeeded in getting the jury to
overlook the key issue of freedom of
speech
and ignore evidence that was so
conclusive that we won in the uk okay
this is great this is the key part here
she says i'm sadder still
then losing the case that i seem to have
lost a right i thought i had as an
american to speak freely and openly
she's saying that the fact that she's
not allowed to defame johnny depp
means that freedom of speech is dead in
america i'm so glad she brought this up
because maybe she thinks this sincerely
it seems like kind of a cynical take to
me but maybe she sincerely thinks that
and she should be corrected
there is no freedom of speech
to defamation
you don't freedom of speech doesn't mean
you can just say whatever you want i
wrote a book about this called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is coming out in paperback
this month amber heard claiming that her
loss in a defamation case is the death
knell for free speech is really rich
first of all because the libs in this
country have been attacking the
legitimate tradition of free speech in
america for years now
but also there's never been a right to
defamation
she reminds me of of the dad on south
park of randy on south park where he's
acting drunken and belligerent he's
finally arrested he says i thought this
was america but i thought what happened
to freedom i thought this was america
here what you mean i can't no you can't
act belligerently and and out of order
there are limits to what you can say and
do there's no free speech protection to
fraud there's no free speech protection
to fighting words there's no free speech
protection to obscenity for that matter
it ties right in with the whole
theme of pride month which is we have
the freedom to do whatever we want
that's not freedom
we have the right to do whatever we want
it's not what a right is
in the words of edmund burke people do
not have the right to do things that are
not reasonable and not to their benefit
you do not have the right to cut off a
healthy arm just because you have some
fantasy about wanting to be crippled you
do not have the right as far as i'm
concerned to cut off other healthy body
parts just because you have a sexual
problem or confusion and a sick cruel
society is encouraging that delusion in
you you don't have any right to that
that's actually very very wrong
rights are reasonable things
rights are in accord with reality and
logic and reason and what is beneficial
to you and what leads to human
flourishing
do you know how hard it is to win a
defamation case in america it's very
very hard
we have robust speech protections here
and still the evidence was so clear here
that heard was living in a fantasy world
well it's not just amber heard living in
that fantasy world defining her own
truth her own reality it's everybody in
this country these days
this goes back to planned parenthood v
casey to one of the worst supreme court
decisions in american history where the
romantic poet of the court anthony
kennedy said that people
at the heart of liberty lies the right
to define our own concept of existence
of the mystery of human life there is no
right to define your concept of
existence there is an obligation to live
in accord with reality that that's an
obligation
if we're all just defining our own
concept of existence society is going to
break down instantly
because we can't communicate with one
another because our misbegotten notions
of rights and entitlements are going to
come into conflict with one another the
legitimate right of a woman to use the
women's bathroom in peace
conflicts with the pretend right of a
sexually confused man to go into the
women's bathroom those both can't be
rights you both of those people don't
have the right to define their own
concept of existence actually neither of
them do they both have an obligation to
accept
reality
i'm glad you like that clip now
ring
ding subscribe listen guys this is pride
month okay
i don't know what that has to do with
anything but come on all right this is
when we've got to get serious you got to
be inclusive you got to be diverse you
got to open your mind to lots of new
opinions and notifications ring ding
subscribe do what you got to do apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe there as well to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you